welcome to this video this is a new part
in our series on viewer games yeah and
this is a game that was sent to me by
the white player here Jared plane yeah
jared is rated about 1,800 1,800 1,850
this this kind of range and he's playing
someone well I'm never sure what to do
with the name of them um of the opponent
here so i'm going to say and then yeah
he's rated about 1,850 as well so we
kind of haven't even met him yeah this
is played in a in a regular classical
time control game in an open tournament
in Australia so let's get going and we
have it opens the silly in here and then
night off one of the most popular chess
openings and deservedly so it tends to
lead to very interesting unbalanced play
and we would see in this game a typical
example of that um yeah here why don't
move 6 has a big choice and Jared goes
for Bishop c4 system line that was
favored by by Bobby Fischer in the 1960s
and I think he even played it in the
match against Spassky once or twice a
lot quite sure if I know that Spassky
played this um this line played the
night off what they might got to it from
the classical Sicilian but Bishop c4 was
definitely featured in the match yeah
this line is not very much on vogue at
the moment on the top level which does
not mean none yeah then it is some isn't
good or or anything like that if you
choose your lines you should mostly be
guided by as long as their fundamental
soundness by the kind of play that comes
up if you enjoy it Bishop c4 is an
interesting middle-of-the-road move it's
not as let's say strategic and spear
should be to us which very often is
slightly into somewhat
slowish play and it is also not as sharp
as Bishop g5 is which very often after
things like that or similar lines over
here the poisoned pawn is a very
notorious variation can lead to complete
chaos where you really have to to know
things in and out I mean you cannot play
that just over the board 3 it's it's
difficult at least so Bishop c4 as kind
of a middle-of-the-road move and said
somewhat sharp but it's not not like
insanely complicated yeah black went six
this makes sense here to blunt this
Bishop and we would see some of that
theme later Bishop b3 and b5 yo that's
completely normal and now white our your
castle that is nowadays main
continuation actually in the 60s when
Fisher started with the is called the
the Fisher souls and attack um he played
f4 there to play a 5 this some idea is
in fact fairly logical he wants to get
the e6 pawn to move to capture or to
move forward and then get a good
diagonal him it is a pretty logical
continuation but it does weaken the e4
pawn very much and Fisher himself he
showed the antidote in the late 60s
against Robert Byrne this is actually a
very famous game in them in this opening
I'm just going to show you one key
moment it's far away from our main game
but it's very interesting for the
historic context of this here Fisher
played the excellent move h5 which
nowadays looks totally normal because
you see h5 all of the time in the night
off when black has not cancelled and
sometimes when he has canceled and this
is a yeah it's a flank poor move that
however intends to play h4 kick the
night g3 away and therefore influences
the center so with h5 you actually
battle for the center this is not some
kind of d
centralized nonsense also it fights for
the Center for the poverty for ya and
burn didn't find anything better than
the move age formed after which he
already was in terrible shape this this
this this and Fisher one this very
convincingly yeah this game was
basically the death spell of the f4 idea
and people to try to find other ideas
for why and what they came up with is
after this which happened in the game is
the move Queen f3 this is important i'm
not just telling you random opening
stuffy because we would see in the game
why this is preferable um queen of three
years that may move nowadays it gets
this at the end of the game the rook is
hanging on aid and makes it a bit
difficult for black node to develop if
you just play here what is able to
sacrifice you with great effect this
will get three points and blacks king
position is completely destroyed and in
general white intends to play or to
initiate a piece play based initiative
on the kingside a famous game there's by
Kasparov Kasparov against Boris Gelfand
actually in 1993 salsa how long golf and
is playing in top leather chest yeah i
just want to show the initial moves this
is this was is what happened in the
power of game would you one Bishop power
and now night here before knowledge 11
why did was Knight to f4 and he had all
those pieces concentrated on the king's
son and got a decisive King side attack
let us look what happened in the game
because this is really important to
compare here white has all pieces on the
Kings side what Jared did was he played
rookie one that looks normal right way
of protecting efore castles and yeah
Bishop g5 normal developing move Queen B
6 yeah you can debate if this is this is
strictly necessary black was probably
not
much liking the look of that which I can
understand it's not a clear clear
there's no clear verdict on this kind of
position but I understand that like
maybe did not want that so we went with
Queen to be 6 first Bishop e3 back yeah
can can play that Quincy 7 it was was a
temple the bishop 1g5 was um
questioningly placed anyway yeah and now
we come to this moment where white now
of your place f3 this is a very safe
move he wants to get this pawn chain
completed so that Efus is protected
however in this position if you look at
this it's a little bit difficult to come
up with an active plan for white it's
really not that easy how are you going
to play as wide what is your general
plan in the crisper of game Kasparov hit
the Queen on g3 and he was shuffling all
the pieces over to the King side but
with a pawn on f3 you cannot get your
queen to this threatening position on g3
anymore or at least not in not easily um
in any case it's not easy to find an
idea on the King side if you think about
this I mean you cannot play G for
anything along these lines you just
weaken your own King tremendously you
have knocked castled long here but short
and it's not not easy to come up with
them in a constructive plan forward the
thing is that in comparison Blacks game
is much easier if we look at the next
couple of moves yeah Bishop d7 was
played yes still he was afraid of the of
the sacrifice but it's ok this way you
get the 94 traded and it was traded a
cookie one now yeah white is playing all
the useful looking most Queen f2 that
threatens to win the exchange would be 8
to prevent that and now you're kind of
Adam yeah you can have at a dead end
here what are you going to
with what it's not I mean early I looked
at this a little bit and I couldn't come
up with a very clear constructive plan
the best that I could come up with is
that what maybe should think of this
Bishop which is really not that great i
mean here this Bishop which is not that
great it just always looks at those
pawns him and doesn't really do much I
was thinking maybe it is an idea to um
yeah to put it on see to somehow like 92
c 3 bishop see to this kind of thing and
the night maybe up to d for this is an
idea that i am well i was thinking of
the problem is as mentioned whites plan
is not obvious not clear what you should
do while blacks plan is very obvious he
can just push a 5 be 4 or a 5 a-4 or at
the right moment d 5 which is DD 5 is a
typical Sicilian move that exchanges
against deep on and leaves black with an
extra send upon here is debatable
however because in many cases you will
help by to trade off the b3 bishop which
is not a great piece at the moment flex
plan is easier here it might not be a
substantial hecho anything for black I
don't think that is the case but it is
easier to play for him i believe yeah
our viewer charity played ph1 now which
is kind of a move like i don't know what
to do King edge one is sometimes useful
in the Sicilian whenever the f porn is
moved but IAM this diagonal seemed very
safe at it it's really not necessary
move at all but she may be did not find
pretty much like I also could not find a
good plan I was thinking for example 92
is an idea but here it's a question
black does not meet you but you can play
d5 at this particular moment and will
certainly have a fine position here yeah
I move like f3 it all doesn't look very
very great black has some initiative on
the queenside and a very harmonious
um the alternative is to not move the
night and I was thinking maybe this is
what at some moment may be going for you
high as possible but then black
definitely would start to set his pawns
in motion and in his position like that
he is definitely comfortable black I
think yeah this is still not a good
piece you get the night to hear it's
nothing dramatic for white he's not
losing or so but I think black ass a
little bit a little bit more comfortable
him in the game after King edge one
black player went for Queen B seven and
this is a slightly mysterious move in my
book because well what is this you're
not going to win that you four point
ever it's not clear what this move is
doing i would i would really prefer to
push the queenside pawns so i think just
before would be okay a5 is also possible
but this looks good 92 you don't want to
put it on the edge of the board a 5
threatening a form i think this is a
farm warm straightforward continuation
and the it leads to similar type of
position as before here for example
black again can try to regroup this but
i think this is something that it can be
can be satisfied with um Queen B 7 i'm
not really sure what it is doing to be
honest it's not hurting black much for
example after a 3 which was played he
still could have played a five witcha
didn't he played 97 yeah he in this
whole game is very reluctant to make any
any commitment on the queenside but a
five looked very normally and let's say
if we just check out a line like that
you know this is something that i would
definitely prefer compared to the game
continuation here black has managed to
open up the B file against the B porn C
porn is also potential target while
black has only two
potential weaknesses it just d six and a
four and both are completely safe right
a four is protected by the bishop that
can be retreated if necessary and d6 is
completely safe here I think black has a
has a slight slight advantage because
his play is much much easier and much
much more direct yeah he went a night d7
however I think what he wanted to do is
to put the night on c4 this is actually
what happens in the game it's not a bad
idea but I don't know I would have
preferred to push the pause to make sure
that lines are really opened there's
also a direct problem with the move why
do you play tonight to e 2 which is some
yeah this is not a logical in any way
the idea to remove or to reroute the
bishop is the night is good it's not
doing much on c3 and it might be better
on d4f for something like that however
there was a concrete possibility here
that I think maybe white should have
played I'm not not completely sure them
95 is the move that's something that you
always have to check in the in the
Sicilian the typical night sacrifice in
in this case it I think it leads to
about equal player black defense and
defense correct game um yeah the night
is hanging but if you check it with the
pawn that's really completely out of the
question here white is much much better
yeah we will trade pawn against bishop
and white with um yeah stay there you
will keep the two bishops and if you for
example just look at this kind of
position this is a fantastic piece now
all of a sudden and yeah that it's much
better than then the opposing night so
he takes d5 is not a good idea what is
it that you should do if he moves the
bishop back here then White has night to
be four
and again he will win this Bishop for
the bishop here it is the same structure
that meant as mentioned before does not
give white yeah much in terms of
activity but at least here we'll get the
two bishops um yeah I think the
relatively best con continuation is um
to take with take with the bishop and
after it takes to go e five just
blocking the position here I think why
this may be a little bit better maybe
but it's nothing serious really why do I
play like c3 and f4 and try to open up
the position for his Bishop Pam um black
is not in a terrible shape though this
is definitely a playable position a
typical thing what black can do is like
g6 and canna fianchetto and try to play
at five at the right moment this has to
be very delicately time time though 95
was interesting especially because it
changes the course of the game
completely and quite often people are a
black player probably did not see the
move coming and it would have been there
would have been a good chance that he
would have been somewhat shaken by that
happening it is really often an
interesting psychological effect if you
can play such a move this kind of
sacrifice and the opponent did not
anticipate it he sometimes will not
respond in the best possible way so if
you have a spectacular-looking move that
has some object some objective merit
that it's not bad those kind of moves
are always interesting to consider
simply also because I can shock the
opponent so that did not happen while
played 90 to objectively speaking this
is not not bad or anything I think 95
was was just more promising yeah Black
is now completing his his night to her
here night went to F for you white tries
to shift over to the King side this is
not not bad at all Knight to c4 and here
Jared dropped the bishop back to see one
that's a good idea really yeah we don't
want to give up the bishop at the moma
and it can rather be on c1 where this
some kind of yeah bishops are quite
often not bad on the initial squares
because i still have long-range
capabilities and here in fact whites
long-term plan can be c3 Bishop c2 and
then maybe at the right moment 'if I've
here trying to use both bishops in them
in the King side and the kingside attack
I'm black now play the Bishop to d7
Queen g3 it all looks very logical and
now this is a key moment in this game
black now place a move root b to c 8 and
this is this is some this is a real
mistake in fact tactical or mistake due
to UM due to a technical reason um it
looks completely normal yeah we want to
do something on the C file completely
understandable however white has a very
good reply to the move what black should
have done is king to age eight yeah
acknowledging the fact that the queen is
on the G file opposed to the king and
this is always almost always making for
some kind of technical idea so he should
have played this prophylactic move we
see then after Luke bc8 white now had a
chance that unfortunately he did not
take this is in fact the only moment in
the whole game almost there's a second
crucial moment um where whites play can
be improved upon it has to be said
though that the attacking variations
that are possible are very very
complicated so there's really nothing I
mean why played a good game here but we
just left to look at what was possible
especially considering that they're
checking lines now are very very
instructive the best continuation here
was to either take on c4 play Knight h5
it can be M um can be a transposition
let's start with nine th rabbits
it's almost the same thing what is the
same thing actually yeah okay Queen g7
checkmate there is not much that black
can do against that besides the move g6
he cannot go bishop afraid which would
actually be what you want to play they
don't want to begin your king but this
is not working at all due to wide them
yeah simply taking on yourself yeah and
Bishop takes bishop age 6 will end in a
quick check medium it's really already
made in three or four moves we see that
those pieces on the King side now do a
good job if you remember the curse power
off game because power plate Queen f3 g3
and then put the night over c3e to f4 so
we have kind of similar ideas only in
the Kasparov game it happened in a much
quicker way and here I think black
really in them in the face earlier he
had some chances to to really get a good
good and solid maybe a slight advantage
with the right kind of setup and this
was not possible in the Kasparov game
yeah Black has to play g 6 cm and now
why should eliminate the night the night
is a possible defender while the bishop
on b3 is not contributing to anything on
the Kings side at all so he should take
um it is funny that rook takes e4 can be
very quickly dismissed this is actually
losing rather quickly Bishop g5 is a
very strong move now e 7 is hanging
black cannot take the night check
checkmate no that's very good mate so
what should play too it's very hard it's
very hard now um if he takes them
community X is attacking of the rook
that's a big difference to be takes e4
with B takes e4 the rook still being on
c8 is protecting this rook but here we
actually win a temple on the
a drug and after let's say queen covers
it Knight f6 a king gee 794 black is
busted yeah there's queen age six and
nine f6 and well you're going to not
survive this if king of eight for
example there's also this little trick
blackest is completely destroyed you on
the dark squares that are enormously
week black absolutely has to take with a
pawn just to keep da protected it's
still a winning attack for white but it
is not easy absolutely not the big point
is that the normal-looking move and this
is for example something I'm not sure
what why player calculated but this is
something where you can easily fail
Bishop g5 looks like the most normal
move ever in the other line it was the
winner here there is no difference
thanks to the mate checkmate but
amazingly enough if black takes Queen
takes we see that the rook now on da tis
not hanging and here black has a
remarkable defense age 6 this is just
about holding but it is it is holding in
this situation the queen is attacked and
yeah what I'd really has no no good move
here amazingly if you give the check
King g7 your queen is hanging and where
do you go you can impede of course and
make a draw but you have no one yeah you
have no way forward you can try to
continue the attack of course with other
means if we go back to h6 if you go here
for example the problem is that mmm I
think black can even capture and be too
if he wants I'll move the bishop am but
this is also possible just covering
Essex and why it has no clear forward
Luke d6 Bishop e8 and white is not
winning because the queen is just about
not this did not this arrow but you know
those those quests they are covered I'm
very very difficult to see that before
in this age six month we can look at
Queen h6 by the way this is an
interesting way to continue to
to continue that tech but it seems that
after the capture here chat line like
that is giving white compensation also
we shouldn't forget what already has two
pawns down at Sam that's a good start
sometimes you win a third 400 fourth
born and so on and then it's not really
anymore the case that you are committed
to checkmate um but here it seems that
black black and even taking them would
be to pawn it seems that white gets some
attack some compensation but check
somehow it seems to be a dead end I mean
white really is a little bit out of
attacking forces he just has two books
which are admittedly very actively
placed on the D file but you don't have
a clear way to improve you can check
forever right Queen aah chak chak can
even go here and then start to check
here again but it is really just the
draw if you go back though to the
situation okay to the situation after
this we saw that Bishop g5 is not not
enough to to decide the issue white or
ever between has a continuation that
does probably win the game I don't think
I found her I found a defense there and
the move is e 5 this is very strong and
fairly typical move in in many ways with
e5 you were making sure that in this
porn is blocking the fifth-ranked for
example we are kind of cutting the born
in two and two parts the Queen son in
the King side we just be prepared Bishop
g5 and there are some distinct
differences in this line with Bishop g5
takes and h6 we would see that for
example if black is um let's see let's
say can you play yeah it's hard to tell
what exactly is his defense but let's
let's go D Phi for example here after d5
there again Bishop g5 is possible
but this is again defending if black is
however I think that I hide in line
let's say black is doing nothing and
then there's actually this this one yeah
that's an additional problem we are
threatening it takes 26 now it's really
it's really a big big problem to defend
this position ad5 is a relatively
toughest move after which again Bishop
g5 is not not enough but white has two
very strong attacking continuations that
are maybe about equal value I think
Knight f6 does win jack yeah black has
to take it it's it's important to note
if black is not taking and going to g7
then Bishop h6 is killing you know the
capture is check check check mate it's
direct directly made it and if he goes
here we go here for Bishop g7 and again
we are threatening made them Rukia ok
and white wins Queen h7 made or Bishop
takes in seven yeah it's a that is far
far too much pressure he has to take
them Bishop takes yes and now White has
a simple plan of course here here here
and made if black tries to cover that
with the Queen for example Queen B 6
queen and for Quincy five there should
be three Queen back White is going to
get something like this the fianchetto
here g7 and this is this is deadly why
does threatening to get a look on the
fourth rank and then strength sacrifice
on edge so I'm talking about something
like this let's say this-this-this check
check check mate and mate yeah and this
is actually impossible to defend against
at least them defend in a couple of
moves it's not like happening
immediately but very very very very
short order if black is playing D Phi
for example to try to cover both squares
we are still going here because of the
default pin and again all thread is
Queen h7 in a move of a move like sorry
h5 is coming then Queen g5 Queen h6
Queen h8 mate is deciding the issue yeah
it's it's a deadly attack instead of
Knight f6 there also is a move rookie
for by the way this is quite interesting
it's a simply prepares to swing the rook
over here um if black is playing nothing
move now I mean ok that's a queen bee 6
that's not exactly nothing but it's it's
attacking the rook then you can just go
over here no it is a deadly attack now
Knight f6 is again a threat in this
position a very big one and if black
takes the rook we're just going to
recapture it is pretty hopeless if black
takes everything because the attack is
totally only happening here on the dark
squares the dark squares are completely
exposed and you could give black I mean
if you want you could put give for extra
rooks yeah a 7 b 7 a-8 b8 even a couple
of queens is still going checkmated um I
hope I'm not talking nonsense yeah maybe
if you have a queen on the 7th you can
defend or so but you know the attack is
super strong it's impossible to to
defend against that dark squared attack
and well here I mean black has a new
movie if you do something like this then
this is definitely the size of now as if
we think of a similar situation here the
rook being on the edge file is making a
big difference made in two ways and
black has no way to cover that yeah it's
it's really strong here rook t4 and
Knight f6 they are both winning so this
means with night h5 white could have
gotten
probably decisive attack I mean I
invested some time to check it but I
couldn't find the defense for like maybe
there is something but it is really
really dangerous yeah and black now
played as move that I think is a bit
strange to be honest he played the move
on g6 it wouldn't it wouldn't have
occurred to me I think I think King age
eight again would have been my my choice
sorry h force plate i have to have to
give you that information h4 is the move
that Jared plate and now black played g6
which kind of probably makes clear why I
find this strange because you're playing
g6 and now you're kind of justifying the
h5 move that is the age for move that no
h5 is possible i was thinking king edge
aight looks far more far more normal and
it is actually also funny that if you
look at this age for let's say black is
completely ignoring everything yeah and
we have the same position as before with
a 5 and h4 inserted here night h5 is not
as powerful it's quite interesting
because if we look at exactly the same
line a 5d 59 f 6 chatting stinks here we
see that the extra move h4 is actually
hurting white a little bit because you
don't have like h4h six possible or look
aged form I look to h4 via d 4 so the
poor move is a little bit yeah favorable
for black in comparison the thing is
that this position is still good for
wider the d7 Bishop is terrible and the
dark squares remained weak but it's not
as convincing as it was one move before
um yeah but black played g6 maybe he
really have was irritated by this
possibility and therefore when g6 I
still would have play would play a king
AJ but okay g6 age five yeah and now
black plate um yeah actively Bishop f6
is what you play it and this is this is
very risky
and probably probably not a very good
one he could have played um also a move
like and this is probably what I would
consider to play something like Bishop
back to aid that looks passive but it
does help to cover this complex of
squares and yeah I think black is still
fairly solid here White has some ideas
like this and get the bishop bag and
yeah he has some play now with the age
pawn of the board but i think the the
situation is fairly unclear bishop f6
saw evan now I think leads to a wide
advantage with with best play Jared did
take down that's good takes and takes on
c4 that's also good and now black took
with the rook yeah we have to check what
happens what would have happened if you
would have taken with the pawn after
that white has a strong continuation but
something that is not not totally easy
to find the best move for white here
it's not about capturing on the six or
so but II five the idea behind the
movies that if Bishop takes which looks
very normal white is going to take and
take on g6 and this is a decisive attack
why do we win this the discoveries that
he has with Knight e5 e7 and so on I
really really tough to to to answer
unless you take on g6 so black would
have needed to take on g6 and then where
is it here it's long check ya hear white
retains a very good position the normal
looking move Bishop g5 is probably not a
sufficient for a win after Luke f8 as
it's still white has chances and yeah I
already have a pawn you will gain one to
two more pawns but I think in comparison
there is a better continuation after
this after King edge aid white should
play
Queen f6 a check yeah so King g8 cannot
go here this is check this is now
definitely next not this way we can go
directly there and check made so King GA
it has to be played and now the movies
Bishop to h6 this is a difference queen
to g7 mate it's a threat and if the
bishop only eight moves and on the seven
moves and he has to it's the only way to
cover g7 yeah like bishop here then
white will take on d eight and we'll
come up with a very very clear advantage
that probably should be enough to them
for the win we have one pawn v5 is very
weak all black pawns a week in fact and
very important white still has a defense
a defense of Pawn shield around this
King where blacks king is completely
open so wide white should we name this
is if when black if black takes on d5
with the bishop taking away the pawn
however after night h5 is not much
better Bishop g7 and Bishop g5 we have
again have this attacking idea all of a
sudden this big attack is coming here on
the dark squares after it moves like
queen bee to for example white will take
and just go here ignoring any material
that the rook we want to play this and
checkmate and black really has no
defense he can go efore and yeah give up
the whole look down that's okay that's a
look Jack like black rly is out of out
of Defense's here after you five he will
probably lose the game so it was a very
good opportunity with them with this if
black would have taken on c4 with the
pawn he did not he took with the rook
and here again White has some em yeah a
very important moment when he has to
decide what to play
um there are tempting continuations
Geraden Jarrett's move is some is
interesting and leads to a wide attack
that is not easy to repel and he took on
g6 i'm going to show you that before i
look at the move that was not played of
you can probably guess the move Knight
h5 again was a very interesting
possibility and one that probably would
have won the game at least I couldn't
find the defense it's not easy however
to find all the key moves that are then
unnecessary there um yeah what should
black do f6 saying was check so let's
say he goes all the way back in the
corner then Queen h4s decisive with the
tempo yeah with the rook now away from
c8 the d8 ruke is hanging again and
something like this is a fairly simple
business with Bishop h6 coming oh yeah
again it's usually Bishop h6 that we win
something like that is also quite
convincing so black cannot go to h eight
but he has to move the the bishop
somewhere the the toughest is probably
Bishop to e7 and again why this coming
with Bishop g5 tempo yeah tempo on the
bishop there that's very important yeah
and here black I don't think he has
anything to to defend their Bishop c6 he
can play and here it is interesting
again that night f6 check check is
premature due to King here problem is
that here white has nothing more than
check giving checks but he cannot win
anymore this is not winning due to King
age 6 check check and now we we are out
of checks if you go here neck will take
this gladly and wind with two extra
pieces so we don't have a decisive win
there or the size of continuation there
but white handle belt has of animals
again if I
move that we have seen before this idea
and now Knight f6 is a big threat yeah
if black now would play em gather
something like that let's say we have 9
f chess and we're going to win as king
g7 check wish your age six leads to
check mate check not sure what the
software to David this is checkmate
check check this barato a little bit
check checkmate gets made it them so we
asked to take and after Bishop takes
this is just too much yeah the idea to
play Queen on the h5 queen age adis
impossible to defend against what d5 is
also quite quite terrible but it was
some shown here too to see them
attacking possibilities that that are in
the position yeah blood black should do
is the relatively best defense and it
looks kind of strange is i think bishop
f3 is what the computer is giving that
is at least a little bit tricky because
after check check check Bishop h5 in
this particular moment it's quite funny
that Bishop takes dat M which looks
completely normal yet taking the rook
it's not not easy not easy to win um
because black has this funny reply you
have based on on this little thing and
well what my twin year but hmm yeah it's
not really totally totally cam it's much
easier to not take the rook and just
play a move like Queen to e3 and tending
queen age six and checkmate and black
really has no defense against that if he
covers that with the king then we can
take we don't run into rook g4 with
tempo so we have time now if he goes
through g42 just defend here with Ruby
too and all is fine we just basically a
rook up yeah that was night age five no
Knight age five again was the key
attacking possibility that was possible
it was not played Jared took on g6 with
the night at a very tempting move of
course now let's have a look this is
clear jack takes takes so what might
this have here he has three pawns for
the piece that's good yeah it's um I
mean you industry shouldn't get into the
habit of just counting pawns and so on
but three points is kind of ok 44 for
peace it's very much always about the
positioner in those kind of unbalanced
material situation um yeah well three
points you have and you have the tech
definitely blacks king is is kind of
unsafe and black now is also limited to
a couple of replies he can only play to
Moosa the move on rook fa displayed in
the game and the move loop dc-8 as wide
were threatening to double them in a
situation then this would be a deadly
pin if that would be in effect this was
possible and I think not a bad defense
on the bishop h6 for example here here's
a queen him black will be able to trade
Queens and I think he has decent chance
is to to to get a draw at the end he
will always have counter play with his
pieces against the pawns and tone yeah I
think black has decent chances here the
move rook f8 what he played is also not
bad but we see it's not not an easy task
Bishop age 6 yeah very normal luke t 1
was also possible and it could list you
something very similar to what i just
showed but okay Bishop f6 was played and
now we come to the I mean there were
very critical moments before but here
it's a decisive moment for the black
player he now has to of course do
something else Queen g7 made and what he
should have done is he should have
played Bishop to see a back
this would have been would have been a
good continuation covering here on the
seventh-ranked after that I think it's
about equal I mean why do we probably
play here here and then what can think
of just keeping the Queen's on at least
for the moment and here well this is
compensation white has three pawns and
an initiative very often this game will
end in some kind of Perpetual it's it's
hard to give a conclusive line but let's
let's just say he takes it takes him
yeah it's not force now it's just
something that check can easily happen
and here we see the perpetual already
takes check in case check check check
this is this is going to be a jacket
petrol it's just a sample line a
possibility that might have happened if
black would have gone for this defense
he played something different instead of
bishop CA let's go back he played this
and I think after that he's probably
lost but he could have defended better
ed one is good of course attacking d7
and heaven and I a drupe d8 if possible
and now now here black really really
really really had to find the only
defensive moves on and I think Quincy
eight gave some chances of survival but
not I mean it's not great really um I
think the best move here for why does c3
this is actually tanzania if we stuck
like that this kind of thing but after a
bishop move I'm not sure that wide wins
black can also take care yeah that's a
check something like this it's not
entirely clear white has rook and pawn
against the rooks to looks and the pawn
against the Queen but White's King is
also not totally safe I'm not sure that
white win cm it is easier if we go back
to not take on f7 but to start with c3
and keep like in this bind yeah black
really has a heart
to move any any office pieces something
like let's say Luke c7 and then maybe
just be five Queen somewhere I know f4
so and why it has tremendous pressure
here yeah 3 points big initiative will
be very difficult to defend for black
and as you can see there are maybe more
pawns dropping in the near future
however this is what that was blacks
best option what he did in the game he
played he played this and here there's a
moment if you want to take take a couple
of seconds to pause the video you can
find a winning tactic here for wide that
Jared plate and after that it's
basically over okay i'm going to show
the move now why it played this check
and one yeah a queen sacrifice that wins
basic hot pieces yeah yeah the rook
chatteris bishop when we win the Queen
check and yet another bishops white is
coming from being a piece down for two
pawns to being a piece up with aunt is
the last some parts yeah black in fact
continued the game for quite quite a
long while um yeah you never know about
the time situation some of my end my
computer is not hello it's not putting
out the moves kind of Hanks let's see
you said that what is this okay so it's
it's a bit strange now it well no it's
doing something okay yeah I mean it's
not that interesting anymore because
really it is a piece and two pawns but
it continued for a little bit but there
was nothing special happening white got
rid of the queenside chance and
ultimately back here I go to a king and
porn and came
whether porn some check ponsor need to
promotion at the new queen yeah that was
a very interesting battle here in the
open Sicilian kind of typical for the
opening I think that um there were a
couple of key moments I think that what
to take from this game for for the white
player is in the opening if we start
with that it's probably not a great idea
to set up with f3 in this kind of line
because you lack active ideas that you
can really go for later a queen a three
base set up is probably more promising
black I think played a bit too slowly on
the queenside I think around here I
really would have liked to see him
though so spawn pushes but he never
never played that and um yeah then we
got them yeah 95 was another interesting
moment but then we got to this to this
situation where instead of age 49 h 5
what's the more the more dangerous
attacking continuation and this is also
something that yeah if you look at how
it attacks are developed it's very often
the case that you need some kind of porn
move ahead of the king like here the
castle in position is totally totally
sound and you need to provoke some kind
of poor move to really get somewhere and
if you see night h5 you see that g6 has
to be played as Bishop f8 fails to this
and this this alone should really
attract you to the move Knight h5
because now you see that those attacking
ideas will develop on the dark squares
this is some simply quite typical it's
it's however possible that you come here
to this point and you see maybe that
this move sorry that Bishop g5 is not
not working due to the capture and age
six and this could maybe deter you from
playing in the move but in general a
piece based attack here that provokes
weaknesses is more promising than
pushing the porn
in the game wyd again a little bit later
got the chance instead of sacrificing to
play this it's that's however entirely
different situation ibly because 96 also
looks quite tempting yeah and after
night g6 white short pretty substantial
initiative and three pawns and black
relatively quickly failures like this
with this rook c8 move that allowed the
decisive Queen f7 combination which was
found and in played by our view here
Jared yeah I hope you enjoyed this game
it was a funny funny is wrong and it was
a very I think an entertaining attacking
game funny is the wrong word it wasn't
entertaining attacking game where there
were many interesting possibilities I
think those night h5 based attacks are
quite instructive to look at yeah I hope
you enjoyed that and yeah i'm going to
do those some viewer games little bit
more little bit more regularly but i
really couldn't do anything in the last
two weeks I was totally swamped with
stuff and ya know I've got a little bit
more time to do additional videos yeah I
hope you like that thanks for watching